hello and welcome to this video playing
Peregrine 64 yeah Queens gambit we get
I've played him five times three wins
and two draws I feel like I was lucky in
the drawers I have this kind of memory
it not very specific but I think
something weird happened down okay
anywhere anyway I'm going with this
somewhat modest approach against his son
Rogozin yeah I'm be transposed to a new
Mizzou Indian mainline old main line
this when I'm playing here somehow got
popular in recent years not totally sure
why to be honest because it's hard to
believe that as i QP position should be
anything fantastic but ok i'm definitely
not complaining let's see about this
queen t so i need to make sure that d 4
isn't happening easily I have always
night a 4 against e4 yeah mmm yes night
b-52 d4 certainly was some a possible
way of playing yeah 92 is an easy choice
to go to defy it's not very active
though so I'm not so happy with it
Bishop a3s just the moment he played it
i became a more aware of this
possibility it is not easy here at all
to prevent night before and pressure
against them a two
hmm 22 is got night reform hmm it's not
so nice huh
you have a cheek hmm not good not good
at all yeah Queen d2 yeah I'm not happy
with it yeah that 92 move was probably
just bad yeah 94 them a good move now I
have to take plenty play 94 if he goes
94 maybe I can start with push away
through a three but it's not a big deal
yeah does this is not good yeah well
maybe it's it's still not terrible for
me but yeah maybe it isn't so bad
actually 96 now Scott Brooks is six well
then Bishop e3 hmm
it should be a three-year opt to but
should be seven so kind of okay okay
so route takes bishop a three Queen the
group d to Bishop e7 he takes with the
palm did I overlooked something probably
probably I miscalculated horribly here
hmm now I can take you two should be 72
it's lame it's really lame and now I'm
getting kind of ambitious in here we
just do this after year some rectus
structure them probably i calculated
some nonsense there with Roxy 6 because
why wouldn't he play that hmm yeah so
here my structure is better the question
is can I maintain this like c5c for
certainly comes into consideration here
for black and I get to to block
everything I'm in very good shape small
screen III probably okay this is also
quite interesting let's do it night each
five becomes a possible to you and also
just taking off call so he probably has
to move the bishop somehow and it
doesn't have good squares rube d2 just
gets answered by Queen e5 that doesn't
do much I have to pay attention to my
time
yeah not easy
ok so i can now take and play play
technical probably have to yeah just
kinky em and drugged up is pretty nice
position bouquet five comes yep then
maybe I could have chicken only six but
I don't know if that's a fantastic idea
check ok so just take here
it should be somewhat better for white
anyway I need to need to be quickly this
is the thing threatening to take both
pawns now all 96 takes rook takes I take
both I pawns it's not so easy for me to
move the bishop because of his feedback
rank Bishop d7 group d 6 which should be
8th time morning yeah this one okay but
if I take on tick there it's a it's a
mate thread first so you cannot grab you
three ok black resign yeah it's a
winning ND now the other was somewhat
strange I definitely didn't play the
opening well this is the line that is
played sometimes I think they play a
three before by the way now that I think
of it again yeah it's probably better
yeah I hear black is definitely okay
whatever I do it looks weird the engine
wants to do this which doesn't look so
bad but well how how good can there be
an the bishop is here queen is quite
annoying okay this was my move now ticks
ticks and go to the four yeah the engine
actually likes my position I didn't
expect that and here you can take 1 D 2
oh that's all I didn't think of it all I
was just thinking I'll take this was
check but wow ok check which room shakes
and I'm totally lost you know I didn't
actually see that this is
tected whoa okay so that was a huge mess
he took there and yeah i was thinking
rook cheeks after which I wanted to take
here and I thought it's roughly equal i
saw this which is actually this is a
correct line yeah this was best better
than what he did but he could have just
one right with this room teacher Wow
yeah now I'm better just have the
clearly clearly more comfortable
structure here black is in trouble yeah
the engine confirms gives me roughly one
pawn damn I can also take you for hear
it this is a very good ending yeah I
could have taken only six also it's also
strong but this is also good route to a
five check high-end reduce Bishop d7 and
says black holes well how does that hold
f5 ok there's g5 now ok I come here and
the engine says this is equal wow it
looks like complete completely bad for
black like be for a three
and maybe I don't make any progress here
I mean structurally speaking it looks
like blood is it huge trouble my light
is also not getting in the game quickly
now probably the engine is right even
though it looks bad yeah and around here
we have a have a winning ending yeah
there was a lucky winner you could have
taken on D to a move that I simply
didn't have on the radar i was just not
seeing that e7 is actually protected who
ok well thanks for watching